bonjour si vous regardez cette vidéo
c'est que nous avons dépassé le premier
palier de la campagne de financement de
la saison 2 de peignoir et ça fait super
plaisir
grâce à cette somme on va pouvoir
tourner la saison 2 de taïwan donc c'est
super et un énorme merci à toutes les
personnes qui ont déjà donné de l'argent
comme je vous le disais donc avec 5000
euros on va pouvoir tourner certes de
manière un peu plus modeste que pour la
saison une comme je disais dans la vidéo
de présentation et sur la page et l'uil
il nous faudrait six mille euros pour
pouvoir tourner dans les mêmes
conditions que la saison une donc pour
l'instant on peut tourner en défrayant
les gens en les nourrissant et en
rassemblant un petit peu de matériel
technique accessoires costumes
si on veut pouvoir rémunérer un petit
peu tous les gens qui investissent qui
s'investissent dans la série il nous
faudrait au moins 6000 euros
donc comme la campagne n'est pas
terminée je vous invite à continuer de
partager cette vidéo la vidéo de
présentation la page de bulles parlez-en
autour de vous à toutes les personnes
qui pourraient être intéressés qui
aiment la science fiction l'histoire
l'humour les webséries youtube ou la vie
et ben voilà en espérant que ça continue
de grimper et qu'on puisse vraiment
faire quelque chose de très qualitatif
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo et j'espère à la prochaine qui
annoncera un qu'on a atteint notre
panier ça serait super et en attendant à
bientôt et encore merci